hi i'm beau carnes with freecodecamp.org
in this course i'll be teaching you how
to build a hackintosh
a hackintosh is a non-mac computer
built with pc parts that runs the mac os
operating system
in this course we'll be building a
computer that runs mac os
big sur the main benefit of building a
hackintosh
instead of just buying a mac is that it
is way cheaper
in this course we'll be creating a
computer that matches the mac pro
specs but for less than half the price
and you can get the price down even
cheaper if you don't need the power of
the mac pro
i've heard about people creating a
hackintosh for less than one hundred
dollars
it's not illegal to create a hackintosh
but it does go against apple's
end user license agreement so don't
think you can just take it to an apple
store for repair
also in some place it is it is illegal
to sell a hackintosh
this course has two parts in the first
part i will show you step by step
how to build the system that we're
turning into a hackintosh
in the second part i'll show you how to
install the mac os
big sur operating system using open core
if you already have a computer you want
to use you may be able to just skip to
the second section to learn how to
install mac os big sur
many computer parts work for
hackintosh's but not all of them
in the description i have a link to a
page that will show you which hardware
works for hackintosh's
if you want to be safe you can just use
the exact parts i used
and in the description i have a link to
all those parts but feel free to mix and
match
just make sure to confirm that the parts
you use are compatible with the
hackintosh
when i show you how to install mac os
you can follow along
no matter what hardware you use however
there are some parts where it does make
a difference what hardware you have
but i'll point that out and show you how
to figure out what to use for your
specific configuration
also one thing to note is that to
install mac os like i show
in this course you will have to have
access to another computer with mac os
we'll be using mac os to create the mac
os installer
that we'll use to create the hackintosh
but maybe of a friend or co-worker that
will allow you to borrow their map just
for a little bit so you can create the
installer
i'm going to personally use this
hackintosh that i create in this course
to do a lot of video editing and
graphics so i just wanted to make sure
it was powerful enough
and that's why i tried to make the specs
line up with the low end
mac pro with a few upgrades i also
wanted to make sure that the computer
looked pretty cool
many years ago i used to build computers
and this is the first one i've built for
a while
and it was just interesting seeing what
things stayed the same and what things
have been
have changed since then okay let's start
by looking at the parts that i chose for
the hackintosh
okay got this case because i like that
has this little window here
uh it's going to be cool to be able to
see everything inside i have some things
that are going to create
different lights and make it look cool
inside and i said one of my my
main things i'm thinking about is what
it's going to look like and it's going
to fit everything i need
and then we got this motherboard here
it's going to have all the ports that i
need
it has some good cooling and i got this
gpu cooler and it does have some
leds on here so to make it look cool
inside
and this should be more than enough to
cool my gpu
and speaking of gpu we got this eight
core
gpu and it's intel and for
hackintosh's intel's are often more
likely to work you can always check the
description where we hit or i have a
link
of the different parts are going to work
but a lot of different parts will work
with the hackintosh
and then we have our gpu here now the
gpu
i got because it was similar to what the
mac pro had
and also because it was this specific
gpu this specific graphics card was on a
list of graphics cards that are supposed
to work with final cut pro
and i'm going to be con commonly using
this computer to edit videos on final
cut pro
so that's why i got this specific
graphics card and then we have our
hard drive here our two terabyte hard
drive
now this is a little upgraded compared
to the default mac pro hard drive
but with doing a lot of video i think
i'm gonna need a lot more space
and then we got our ram here i got 34
gigabytes of ram so this is going to be
really good for video editing we're
going to need at least 34 gigabytes
64 from my research the next step up
that sometimes people get 64. but
that's going to be a little overkill we
probably won't for my purposes i
probably won't need that much ram and
you may not even need 32 gigabytes you
may be able to get by with 16 gigabytes
i'm going to be plugging my computer
directly into
our network our into our internet
instead of using wi-fi i'm going to go
right through a cable
and i did get the magic track pad for
two reasons one i love using the
trackpad on my laptop
and i want to see how easy it is to get
official mac parts to connect to our
hackintosh
and then i got a power supply so this
should be more
650 watts should be exactly what we need
or even more than what we need for it to
run all these things
and then i did get a new monitor so i
got full hd
so it's going to be more similar to the
resolution
on my macbook pro okay well let's start
by taking the motherboard out of the box
and this is a refurbished motherboard
but it should work just as well
don't need any of these things nope got
some cool stickers here
so just put all this extra stuff off to
the side
and we got some cables and what i'm
going to do
is actually well first i'm going to
empty this box
got a bunch of things and then i'm going
to put it just
close the box and i'm going to use the
top of this box
to do the build on this will be like a
little platform
and you do have to be careful with
static electricity so
so you want to touch something metal
like maybe the case so i'm going to
actually just touch the case to kind of
get all the static electricity off or
maybe you have one of those little ra
there's these little things you can put
around your wrist that will help with
static electricity
but i should be fine for just touching
something metal or this case it will get
the stick electricity off and won't
destroy anything on your any parts so
i'm just
hold this out here
[Applause]
okay so that's pretty nice looking we
got a lot of different
slots to put things in so these are all
the built-in stuff
see we even even have a usb type-c we
have hdmi
now we're not even going to use this
hdmi because we have the other graphics
cards
but we'll be using a lot of this usb
we'll be using the
the ethernet cable port and then we have
we have the audio built in here so and
we won't be using this slot here
obviously because we'll be using the usb
and so this is going to have everything
we need here okay now i'm going to grab
the cpu
got the cpu here that's the first thing
we're going to install into the
motherboard
so i got some scissors so i can just
kind of
open this here and we'll take this out
of the box
okay and the cpu is just this little
thing in here right here
i think it's focused yep
so this is the cpu we're about to
install right in the motherboard
okay so we have to pop open this thing
right here in the motherboard to install
the cpu so this
there's a little metal thing that can
just move out like this
and so this pops open like this and this
is right where we put the
cpu
so let me take the cpu out
i just have to make sure the cpu is
facing the right direction you see this
arrow
that's going to go toward the outside
and there's these little slots on both
sides of the cpu
you're going to make sure that those
slots line up with the slots right
in the motherboard so let me place this
right into the motherboard
and then we can just close this top
thing right down like this
and this kind of pushes
in place and the cpu is installed
okay now that i got the processor in i'm
just gonna have to pop this off
soon we're gonna install our cooler
that's gonna connect right to the
processor
but first let's install our ram okay
next up the ram
so again this is 32 gigabyte ram and
we're going to install in the
motherboard so let me get this opened
so there's four ram slots but we just
have two sticks of ram
so we're going to install in the second
and fourth slot
which is b2 and a2 that's what they
recommend
when you don't have four sticks of rams
so make sure that this is pushed out
on where you're gonna put in the ram
here so i just push out all of them
and i'm gonna put this one in here first
i'll do the
a2 now if you have four sticks of ram
you just fill in every slot
so i'm going to push this in
until i kind of hear it clicks and then
i can push in this side right here
to make sure it's in now i'm going to do
the next thing of ram push that in
okay and that clicked
and the ram is installed okay now we're
going to start getting the case ready
and then we're gonna get
put the cooler on the processor and part
of the cooler gets attached to the case
so let me grab this now to get the parts
of the case off so we can start putting
things inside so just unscrew this here
okay now let's get the back of the case
open
put this off to the side so one cool
thing about this case is there's a lot
of stuff for
cable management so we're gonna have all
the cables back here to kind of hide
them out of the way and we'll put that
that back of the case in front of it so
we'll kind of hide all the cables that
are going everywhere
and there's little things to put the
cables in and if we already have some
cables kind of going right through here
so let's turn the case back around
okay we'll take this extra packaging out
right here
and this is just an empty well i guess
it's not empty
let's see what's in it
and here just has some extra cables and
some stuff that we'll be using laters
and then a manual here
now we're going to prepare a case to put
things in we could
take these fans out temporarily while we
put the motherboard in
but i'll leave them in for now and then
see if we need to just to see we'll see
if we can fit the motherboard
in or not with those fans there i'm
going to take this part off here
this is where our cooler is going to go
there we go
yeah somebody they're supposed to be you
still be able to use your hands to
untighten these but sometimes they're a
little too
tight i need to use a screwdriver
this bag was in the box i pulled out
from behind the case
just in that slot and i'm going to get
some screws that i'm going to use to
attach the motherboard to the case
so i think these ones are going to be
the screws i'm just going to confirm by
putting them in before i
put the motherboard up
and these are way too big these are not
the screws okay let's try again
i think now i think that these ones are
the screws they're a little smaller
let's see if these fit in
these are the right size so now i'm
going to
use these to install the motherboard
we've got this motherboard
that we're going to install first i'm
just going to peel this off
and then we have to make sure it lines
up and we have all the ports
on the side and we have to make sure
those
ports line up correctly in the case
so they go through the back of the case
it fit in without having to take the
fans off so wait to make sure this is
lined up here
so you can see there's still a gap up
top so i'm going to adjust the
motherboard
so this part lines up with all these
ports here
okay we should be very gentle
but i got the back is now popped out a
little bit
so now i'll get a screw on the
screwdriver
and get one of these screwed in okay i'm
gonna try something new i
it's i'm gonna actually try putting the
case
down i think this is gonna make it a
little simpler to install i probably
should have thought of this to begin
with
okay now i'm gonna get in here and i'm
going to try screwing this in again
i got the motherboard installed
and next up is this hard drive this
solid state drive
it's a pcie m.2 and this is there's a
lot of different types of hard drives
that could work with this motherboard
and case combo but this the type we're
going to be using is a two terabyte so
we just open this up
you can see it right in here so let's
see how to get this thing installed into
this motherboard
for this type of hard drive there's two
places where it can be inserted into
this motherboard
one's under this panel and one's under
this panel so we're going to take off
this panel so we can insert the
the hard drive or the solid state drive
that is
so let's unscrew this
so first we're going to insert this side
into the slot on the motherboard
so let's put over here
okay now to hold this in right here
we're going to have to put this
plate on and this plate's going to
there's going to be a screw that'll go
right in there and hold it on
the back of this actually has something
that we can remove
and it's gonna help the the solid state
drive
stick into place better so let's do that
now
okay the solid state drive is secure
now the exact order that i'm installing
all these parts in
is kind of up to the user you don't have
to install things in the exact order we
could have put the solid state drive in
before we put the motherboard in so it's
okay if you do things a little out of
order but some things just make it
easier
like it's easier to put the motherboard
in before you put the coolant
before you put the cooler on because the
cooler is going to attach to here and
then it's going to attach the processor
but right now we're going to install the
power supply
so i'll get this opened up
okay we got the power supply
let's get this put in the computer
so we got the case turned around and
we're going to insert the power supply
the thing is
the fan should be pointing toward the
bottom of the case toward the floor
so i'm just going to slide this in right
here
and then i'm just going to turn this a
little bit
so i can start screwing this in
the power supply actually came with a
bag they had some zip ties and some
screws so this is what i'll be using to
make sure the power supply secure into
the case
whoops almost lost on there
so i just got to get this screwed in
okay we're gonna get some of these
cables and we're going to snake them
through
so we can get them plugged into our
motherboard i'm pretty sure we're only
going to need this cable the power
supply has a few different ones because
it just depends on what motherboard
you're going to use
so we're going to try to snake this
through here
and we're eventually while we're looking
at it there are some other cables here
these cables are are for our case so we
can see our case has
some ports at the top of the case and
some of these
cables here are going to help us get
those working we have to get these
plugged into our motherboard
so let's see if we can get these plugged
into our motherboard and our power
supply here
so it looks like some of these are
connected to our fans
but right now i'm going to slide these
through here
and some of these will wait till later
to get installed okay let's turn this
around
okay let's get our power supply put in
first
so here's the cable for our power supply
so let's see how this is going to go in
i'm going to have to
kind of turn it a little bit
it's going to be a little tricky because
like a tight
curve here to get in and we just need to
get it to snap into place
okay our power supply is now going to
our motherboard
okay i made a mistake before i the
second cable coming from the power
supply does actually go right into the
motherboard
and it's it's been a little while since
i put together a computer so i forgot
about
some of these steps but now remember
we're gonna put this
right through here because it's going
we're gonna just
it's gonna be in the top corner of the
motherboard so i'm going to put that
here and i'm going to
put this cable through this spot to hold
it in place and i'll use this little
twisty tie here and let's
turn this around okay
in this top left corner we can see where
we're going to
plug in the other cable you can kind of
see in the top left corner there's a
spot to plug that in
so that's what we're gonna do okay i'm
gonna grab the cable
and twist this around i just used two
hands to plug in the cable so we got it
plugged in at the top
corner of the motherboard there all
these cables that were connected to the
other
ports and stuff on the computer we're
gonna have to get these installed too
these are actually there's probably we
can probably make them come up through
here
because these are all going to connect
at the bottom here
so i'm actually going to make these come
up in a different spot
so first let's get this out
and this is going to go right into here
got it
and then here's another one i think this
is the
the audio got that put in
and next basically i'm just looking at
the connections on these cables and
trying to figure out
which parts of the motherboard that
these fit in
so here's another one this is actually
supposed to go over here
but we're going to have to put an
adapter so let me
pop this out here and then i'm going to
put up the other
spot other area so here
now i'm going to get the adapter so
here's the adapter
it came with the motherboard and so i'm
going to put this into one end
and there's these different things here
let me turn around this way
see we have the hd led power sw plead
and the manual for the motherboard
shows where i'm supposed to put all that
stuff in so i'm going to plug the
adapter on one end
and then i'm going to use this diagram
to figure out where to plug in those
other parts
those other cables in
this corner area right here so let me do
that now
okay let's get the
hdd one
okay this power one
and now i just got all of them plugged
in there
okay so now i can just run this cable
back out the
back
there we go okay one of these skills
gonna fit right here
let's see
there we go now
you can just kind of pull these through
here so they kind of get out of the way
a little more
now to plug in the cables for these fans
these fans have cables that are going to
come around and plug in near those other
cables we have this cable
and we have this other fan cable and i'm
going to try to get them both plugged in
to the motherboard
okay i was looking in the manual for my
motherboard and i should have done this
first
it's showing where all the fan cables
should be plugged into for the power
and i had it wrong so let me readjust
some things here and put the fan cables
where they're supposed to be
okay i got both the fan cables and this
cable i'm actually going to run it right
through the top here so it's going to
come around here
and i'm going to run it right through
the top
and i'm just going to leave it like this
because it
takes up some of the slack here and this
cable will run
kind of the way i was originally
thinking right through here
so with the two fan cables let me turn
this around
so if we look at the manual here we have
chaffin one and chaff and two
that's the chassis or or the case so we
see the first one is going to be right
over here
and then the second one is going to be
right here so let's do the first one
right here it's going to be right below
the processor
and it's me right there so let's uh so
that's the one that the cable that ran
through the top
we're gonna plug in right there so you
can see it says
chat one right there and that's where
i'm gonna plug in the cable
and i am going to need some more slack
so i just let out the slack from the
back
and i'm going to take this cable and
just plug it in right where it says
cha one
so here's a good close-up of that cable
plugged in right there now let's get the
other cable
plugged in now here's other fan cable
according to the manual
we're gonna plug it in on this top one
here
so you can see it from this other angle
there's an extra pin
sticking out because the spot on the
motherboard has four pins but there's
only
three sections on the cable and that's
normal so that's what it should look
like
okay so we got both fans plugged in
both of the case fans okay i have two
more major things i need to get
installed
one the graphics card and then
the cooler so i'm going to install this
first
let's get this open this is going to be
one of the most complicated things
that that's going to be in our computer
and you may not even need
a cooler like this this is really if
you're going to be doing things that
take a lot of power
and if you want to try to overclock your
machine
and you just need to make things a lot
cooler you may be able to
get by with something a lot simpler but
this is what
we're going to be installing in this
machine and i'll show you how i do that
so this comes with quite a few things we
have this grill that's going to go up
front
and then this is the part that's going
to whoops
this is the part that's going to attach
to the processor
we have two fans and then we're just a
bunch of miscellaneous items that we're
going to use during the installation
so i'll get rid of this box so just as a
little behind the scenes here's my box
graveyard right here i have a bunch of
boxes and just other things that i keep
discarding as i'm building this computer
we're going to start by getting the fans
installed onto this grille
depending on where you're going to mount
this is which direction the fan is going
to go
but since i'm mounting on the front of
the machine i will face it like this
and then we have our second fan
okay we're gonna find these screws that
we're gonna use to
mount these fans
and they just hand tighten so let's put
this right in here
now i'm going to grab this piece that i
took off of the case
and we're going to mount this to this
piece right here
got these screws
we're going to put that right into the
case here
we got the grill installed now we just
have to connect
the end to the processor
now this part we could have done earlier
it may have been easier
um but with there's these two pieces
like this that we're gonna put on both
sides
okay if you look at this see there's a
slot
at the top of this and this has to go
right into the slot there's gonna be a
slot right here
i'm going to put it and make it line up
with the slot
i'm going to get a screw and i
should have already had the screw ready
i'm going to put this down for a second
so we got i'm going to open this little
bag of screws
and i'm going to put this on here
and the screws actually have to go in
from the bottom
there we go i got the first screw in
well let's get this one in
tighten that up okay now let's do the
other side
now this is going to
line up right here
but we're going to do some things before
we put it on there
see we have this piece and this piece is
going to go on the back of the case
let me put this this stuff in here for
now
i'm going to turn the case around
and this piece is going to go in like
this these are optional you can pull
these off if you want i'll pull that off
so it sticks better
and we're going to line it right up kind
of push
that stickiness is going to hold it on
and then we're going to turn around and
put in some
some little screw things
okay now we have to install these things
open this up
and we just screw them in
and they're gonna go right into the back
that we just put on
and i'm holding the back with my other
hand
they screw into it that one
okay now we're going to add some of this
thermal compound
right to the processor and then we're
going to put
this onto it after
removing this little plastic wrap we're
going to put this on to it
and then there's going to be
four of these little things let's get
focused
we'll put four of these little things on
each corner
for the thermal compound they recommend
just putting a little pea-sized little
dollop on it so let's do that
and now it's very important to remove
this label here
or it's not going to work well
okay now this is
the moment of truth that to push it onto
the thermal compound
and basically press it in
now let me hold it with one hand
and i'm going to start putting these
tops on
okay got those corners in
okay we have two cables coming out of
this pump right here that we just
put on top of the processor one cable is
going to be to run the lights there's
going to be a light that light up right
on here
and the other cable is a power cable so
the
cable for the light that has the bigger
end i'm just going to run this through
the top
because we're going to bring it down
somewhere else later let me just get it
through there
the other cable is going to be for power
so
you're going to look for something on
the motherboard that says pump
and if you look right here i'm just
about to get a close-up but it's going
to be right here
let me show you so you can see right in
there it says
pump so that's where we're going to plug
in the power cord for the pump
so let's do that right now so we still
to adjust this cable so it's out of the
way that goes to the fan right here
but we're going to put the pump power
cable right above that other cable
so
okay now we're going to use this fan
splitter cable that came with the cooler
so we're going to plug this right into
the motherboard where the fan power
supply is
so there's our water pump on the
processor if we look right here
it says you can see where it says cpu
fan
so that's the slot where we're gonna
plug in that cable
okay i'll just plug in just like this
and then the other parts of the cable
i'm just going to run behind
the motherboard
these front fans that we installed from
our cooler
we have all these cables coming off of
it so now we have everything ready that
we can get the power to these cables
uh plugged in so first of all let's get
these cables i'm gonna
run these cables behind this red thing
so we can put them out the back of our
case
okay now i got the cables run through
coming out the back of the case we can
turn the case around
and we have all the our cables coming
out the back now coming out the top we
have our cable splitter
and then we also have the cables from
our fans the power cables
so we're going to take the power cables
from our two fans
and just just plug them into these two
ends of the cable splitter
okay so now we have our fans powered so
we have three more cables that aren't
plugged into anything
and these are the rgb cables and in the
box
we have this three-way rgb splitter so
we are just going to plug each of the
rgb cables
into each of the ends of this three-way
splitter
okay one to here and there are two
little arrows
i don't know if you can see this but the
arrows should line up
the arrow should line up that's how you
know you have it plugged in right
so we have this one
and then the third one
now the case came with these little
plastic things
that's to help pull these uh these
cables together
so we can put this right over the top
here
and that holds these together put one
right here
here's the third one so i can hold all
these three connections together
now i'm just going to run there's one
this end
we're going to plug into our motherboard
i'm actually going to put over here
because that's going to be closer to
where i'm going to plug it in on the
motherboard
so let's turn the case around on the
bottom here
you can see it says
that white that white connector says rgb
on it so that's where we're going to
plug in the cable that we just brought
through
you want to make sure the arrow on the
there's an arrow right here that's going
to be on the left side
that's going to be where the power is
and then the other things are for the
different colors
okay we have one more thing to install
and that is
the graphics card so
let's see how to do that so let's get
this out of its package here
so that looks pretty nice it has these
connections on the end here
and so we're going to have to get this
into our motherboard
and then we're going to have to power it
if you can see this there's a place to
plug a power cable in right here
so if you see on this side you can see
that there's two tabs
here that means it's going to take two
slots
from our case so let's look at that
so you can see these things here all
each of these can be taken out
depending on if what you need to put
into there whatever card you have
and we're gonna need to take out two to
figure out what two to take out
let me kind of place this card in here
we're gonna put into this slot here
and it looks like we're gonna take out
the second and third slots the top
covering will just stay where it's at
so i'm going to take off this one and
this one
and then we're going to put in the card
into this slot here
so i had to take out this one and this
one so i'll start with this one
and then before i put the card in i'm
going to have to take out this panel
right here
so i'll take out these screws let me get
a screwdriver to help
and i'll slide this well i don't even
have to take it completely off i can
just slide it
over so we're going to put the card into
this slot right here
we have to make sure that this is popped
out
so it's see it's kind of goes in and out
so it's going to start it out and when
we put the card in
it will go in and we'll snap in now i
got the card
and i'm going to push it into the slot
so this whole thing
pops in and then these metal tabs
go into the side of the case so that's
what i'm going to do right now
to make sure it lines up with this slot
and then i have to make sure the metal
tabs or the metal part is all on the
side
and just do it very gently and just push
down and wiggle
and it goes right in and you can see
this tab right here
popped down when i push the card in okay
now i will turn the case a little bit
and i'm going to have to make sure the
card is screwed in
so put some screws right here
so these are the screws that that just
held on those little
black panels but now i'm using the same
screw
to screw in the card
and looks like there's some damage on
this metal thing this is a refurbished
card
there's currently a shortage of graphics
cards
so it's it's hard to get good deals on
new ones
and now i can put this panel back
and then twist this and there's one on
bottom i don't know if you can see it
okay now we have to plug in the power
cable right here
okay we're back at the back of the case
and to get the power to the graphics
card
we're going to take this cable that came
with the power supply
and then back here in here there's
a place on the power supply to plug in
this end so we're going to plug in this
into the power supply
and then we're going to run it through
and then we're going to plug this
in to the graphics card so i'm just
going to reach in here and plug it in
i'm not going to show you because it's
just too shadowy in there and it's hard
to even get
my fingers and the camera in there at
once but if you're doing this yourself
you'll be able to easily see where that
plugs in
okay i got plugged into the power supply
and then i'll just run this
right through here
okay got the cable coming through here
and this has a thing where it's kind of
separated so you are going to have to
kind of put them together to plug it in
[Music]
and it snaps right in there and one more
thing i didn't put in the spread earlier
this is a
wi-fi and bluetooth card that
specifically works with mac os
so we're going to need to use this most
motherboards that have built-in wi-fi
and bluetooth
it won't work with mac os so we need a
card that's specifically going to work
with mac os
now at first i was thinking maybe i
don't have to have wi-fi and bluetooth
because i'm going to have
my internet connected through a cable
but the more i thought about it
the more i thought yes i want to have
bluetooth it also helps make other
features on mac os work like
airdrop and i think even imessages
this card is going to go into this short
slot right here
so i just have to pull out the
appropriate cover here
this cable that came with the card is
what connects the bluetooth to the
motherboard
so we have to plug one part into the
card and one part into the usb port on
the motherboard
the cable is going to plug into the
corner of the card right here
we're going to plug the other side right
into that port that says usb
at the bottom of it
so the bluetooth cable is installed i'll
just do a little bit of cable management
here
now with the back of the case i just
have to screw on these antennas
this should be all set up and the
computer is pretty much
done i think i'm gonna need to test it
now
now i already said i haven't really
created my own computer for quite a
while
and if i made any mistakes you already
know because i would have put something
on the screen or somehow indicated that
i made a mistake and i had to redo
something but i don't know yet
so i'm gonna test it this is the moment
of truth i'm gonna plug everything in
and see if it works
okay i got my full hd monitor hooked up
to the computer
i got my usb keyboard hooked up to the
cam with the computer
and now i'm just about to hook up the
power cable
and then i'm going to turn it on
turn on the power supply
now i'm going to press the power button
whoa everything's lighting up
i think everything is working that means
i can finish the cable management and
get the case put back together
and then eventually we'll have to do the
setup you can see on the monitor i don't
know if you can see with a glare but
it's saying that
new cpu installed please enter setup to
configure your system
now that i know the computer works time
to clean up these cables
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay now that the computer is built
we're going to learn how to install the
mac os big sur software
this is the part where you're going to
need a computer with mac os
already on it and we're going to start
with
downloading some of the software we'll
need onto that computer
there are links in the description to
all the software i'm using
we'll get open core and proper tree
we'll also need mount efi and oc gen
x
and you'll soon see what it all does now
i'll download the big sur
operating system right from the app
store
if you're not familiar with mac os you
can get to the app store by clicking the
magnifying glass
in the top right corner and typing app
store
once you get into the app store search
for big sur
click get
and then download
now you will need a usb drive it's best
if it's at least 16 gigabytes
i'm going to format the drive now using
disk utility
to get into the disk utility just click
the magnifying glass and type
disk utility make sure that the view is
set to show
all devices click the usb drive
then click erase in the top menu
you can call the volume anything you
like but i recommend
my volume if you want to use the exact
command
i use later in the video make sure the
format is mac os
extended journaled and that the scheme
is guid partition map
then click the erase button after the
usb drive is prepared
open the terminal in mac os you will
need to use a command in the terminal
to make the usb drive into a bootable
installer for mac os
there's a specific command i have to use
here check the description
for the exact text of the command also
this command is specific to big sur
if you're installing a different version
of mac os i'm going to leave a link in
the description
for the commands for the different
versions if you're installing a
different version
you'll have to wait a bit for this to
install
after this is done open the oc gen x
program
you downloaded earlier to open the
program you will have to right-click the
icon
select open then select open again
this program is optional to use
the software helps us prepare what we
need to install macos
on our particular hardware setup
it will go out and get everything we
need except the ssdts
and put them in a folder for you you can
also do this in a more manual method
by following the open core install guide
which i've linked down in the
description but this program
simplifies things for us on this first
screen under system type choose coffee
lake
this is a reference to the specific type
of processor
i got for this build if you are using a
different processor
you may have to select something
different here
look in your processor's documentation
to determine the name of the micro
architecture it uses
getting this right is very important a
lot of these tabs we can keep
at the default settings under graphics
select whatever green and under audio
select
apple alc under ethernet
select intel mousey you can keep
firmware drivers
at the default setting the sm
bios is important and you have to
specify the correct
system model for this hardware setup
we'll select
imac 19 comma 1. if you are using a
different processor or a different
operating system
this could be different to figure out
what to use
here if you have a different setup go to
the open core install guide
select the section on the left side for
your processor type or chipset
in my case it is coffee lake then find
the heading
platform info scroll down a bit
and you will see a table with the sm
bios to use
so for this build with the big sur
operating system
we're going to select imac 19 comma 1
under system model in the oc gen x
program
finally we'll click the generate efi
button
at the bottom now you can open up the
efi
folder that was just created and see
exactly what's in it
inside there are many files and folders
including an acpi folder
that is empty this folder will be filled
with ssdts
but we now have all the other files we
need including drivers
texts and a config.plist file
which we will be updating in a little
bit
now we'll get the ssdt files
this is different depending on your
processor or chipset
you can find the exact ones you need in
the open core install guide under the
acpi heading
make sure you're in the section for your
processor type
there are four needed for the coffee
lake system click on the first one
ssdt plug
then we'll go to pre-built ssdt's on the
side
and click coffee lake and then i'll
download
all four of these
i have a link in the description to the
page with these ssdts
once they are all downloaded move them
into the efi folder
specifically into the acpi subfolder
in the oc subfolder
now we'll use the mount efi program that
we downloaded earlier
we'll use it to mount the hidden efi
partition
on the usb drive we'll right click
on mount efi.command and click open
then open again
if you get an error like i did you can
open the folder
in terminal and then run the program
with python 3
using the command python 3 space mount
efi dot command
once the program's running select your
usb drive
it should have a name like install mac
os big sur
since we made it into a bootable
installer for mac os
in my case it's option 2. i'll put in
the password for the computer
and now the efi partition has been
mounted
you now have a mounted efi partition and
an efi
folder from oc gen x drag the efi folder
into the efi partition
now we'll open proper tree which we
downloaded earlier
like before you can open it by
right-clicking and selecting open
or you may have to run it from the
terminal with the command
python3 propertree.command
go to file open
select the efi partition then the oc
folder
then open the config.p list file
the first thing we need to do is to
inject all of the files
in the efi folder into the config.plist
file
so we have to go to file then select oc
snapshot
make sure you're on the efi partition go
to the efi folder
and then the oc folder and click the
choose button
a dialog box could pop up here about
what version to use
if this happens click yes now go back to
file
then select oc clean snapshot
and select choose i mentioned that
instead of using the oc gen x
program you can manually do everything
by following the open core
install guide at this point we'll verify
that everything got set up correctly
according to the official install guide
so on the guide for coffee lake we'll
verify these
quirks are set correctly in the
config.plist file
let's see do you virtualize mmio set to
true
enable write unprotector set to false
protect ufi services we do need this in
our system
that's set to true rebuild app memory
map
set to true sync runtime permissions
set to true
and now we do need to set up our device
properties so that our onboard graphics
work
we just need to add this row of
characters
i also have the characters in the
description so just copy it
and put it into the config.p list under
device properties
click on add then right click and choose
new child under add
double click where it says new string
and just paste the text
into the field and hit enter then select
in the next column where it says string
and make sure that it is set to
dictionary
next we need to make another child under
it as you can see in the picture
in the documentation right click on the
text you just added
and select new child
and then then replace new string with
this text here from the documentation
just copy the characters also in the
description
double-click and paste then change
string
in the next column to data and then add
this
set of characters right here in the
third column
again if you have a different processor
type you're going to want to
read this section in the documentation
to make sure you are using the correct
values
now we'll add another new child make
sure the child is under the line that
starts with
pci and not the one that starts with
aapl
replace new string with frame buffer
patch enable
create another new child under the line
that starts with pci
and replace new string with frame buffer
stolen mem now these should both be set
to data not string
and we need to add these numbers from
the documentation
in the third column
now we'll scroll down to the next quirks
section
and here they are in the config.plist
file and we'll just verify that
everything here is set up properly
it looks like these are all correct
because of the oc gen x program
except one more quick thing this disable
rtc checksum
should be set to true this is a quirk
with a specific motherboard i used
and i forgot to record myself setting it
to true
and i'm recording this dialogue later so
just know that this one should be set to
true
now we have to make an update to the
nvram section
so what do we need you can see that many
of these boot args
are already here but we still need to
add a few
so debug equals 0x100
we'll just click into here make sure
there is one space at the end
then copy this over
and then the final thing is to add this
alcid
equals one
now we'll change the language to english
so next to where it says prevlang
kbd change data to string
and set the value to en-us
colon 1 or colon 0 and hit
and hit enter if you need a different
language just go to this link
and you can find out what you should put
in instead
the config.plist file is now done so
we'll go to file
then save we're now completely done
setting up our bootable drive so just
eject the drive
and then you can plug it in to your new
hackintosh computer that you just built
now that we're on the hackintosh i'm not
using screen capture anymore
i'm just recording the monitor of the
hackintosh using a video camera
so the quality won't quite be there
until we get this installed
and then we'll go back to screen
recording so the usb
stick is installed into the computer and
then i'll start up the computer
and then i'll need to get into the bios
so to do that just hit the delete key
and then we'll get onto the bios
and here we are okay so if you get into
the bios and you see it like this
it's called easy mode we want to go to
advanced mode
which is right here you can hit f7 or
just use your mouse
okay so we go over here and set
everything up as default
load optimize defaults okay i'm going to
load them up and hitting enter
now let's go over to advanced this is
where we need to get started
so platform miscellaneous configuration
everything here is fine by default
cpu configuration all of this is good
okay system our vt-d is disabled
that's what we want but we want above 4g
decoding
enabled all right memory configuration
everything's fine graphics configuration
this is if you're going to use your
onboard graphics you would change this
to
cpu graphics but we're not using the
onboard graphics
all right we'll go out of here
okay a lot of these other ones are fine
by default
okay down here where it says serial port
configuration
we're actually going to turn it from on
to off we want the serial port to be off
okay the next thing we need to update in
usb configuration
make sure xhci handoff is
enabled okay now let's go over to boot
boot configuration
we want to turn fastboot off so we'll
disable that
and everything else here is fine
secure boot we're going to change
something we're going to change the os
type to windows uefi mode
now we're ready to save changes and
reset
make sure you have the usb drive in the
computer still because we're going to
boot
right back into the usb drive
okay when it boots we'll press the f12
key
because we want to choose the memory
stick to boot into
now if you get this error message we'll
need to go back to the bios
so let's go back into the bios and we'll
go over here to secure boot which is
under boot
and we want to go down here to key
management
hit that and then click on clear secure
boot keys
say yes now we won't get that message so
save
changes and reset and then i'll
press the f12 key again
okay we come up to our bootloader and we
want to choose
install mac os that's the external usb
drive stick
so hit enter
and now we're going to load the os
okay this is what we like to see once we
get
to this part it's going to be pretty
simple the rest of the time
so we'll click on disk utility and click
continue
and then we'll click this drop down
arrow on view
and show all devices there are my hard
drives
if you don't show all devices you don't
see your hard drive names
so you want to see the root of your hard
drive
i'm going to erase this one
and i just click on erase and then you
can call it whatever you want
i'm going to call it hackintosh
and then you want to choose apfs for
your format
and for the scheme it should be guid
partition map
and then click erase
alright we're done so we'll click out of
here and
we'll click install mac os
continue agree
and agree and this is the hard drive i
just formatted so i'm going to choose it
and click
install
this will take a few minutes here it
goes pretty quick
after the installation finishes the
computer will reboot
and will come right back up to the boot
menu
and then you'll we'll click mac os
installer
it's going to take a little time but now
it's like turning on a brand new mac
computer
so you can just go through the installer
like you're setting up a new computer
choosing the location choosing any
settings that you want
choosing any accessibility choosing how
you want to connect to the
internet i'm just going to kind of go
through this part pretty quickly
because what you want to choose may be
specific to you
it's up to you if you want to sign in
with your apple id
but at this point basically you have a
mac computer but once it finishes
you'll be into your brand new
hackintosh computer running the big sur
operating system
and now we can finally switch back to
screen recording
instead of videotaping a monitor
ah that's a lot nicer now we're on the
screen recording everything's nice and
crisp
there is one more thing we have to do
but first let's just bring up the about
the mac and you can see
we have the 3.6 gigahertz eight core
intel core
processor we have the 32 gigabytes of
ram we have the radeon rx 580 8 gigabyte
graphics card everything looks great
now we have to copy the efi folder from
the hidden efi partition
on our usb stick we're going to need the
mount efi
program to access that partition so i'll
just open up safari search for mount efi
go to this link here and then download
the zip
now open up the folder in my downloads
right click on mount efi dot command
and go to open and then go to open
just hit ok we're going to have to mount
two efi partitions we're going to have
to mount the efi partition
from our hackintosh drive that's the
drive that's the name of the drive
on our hackintosh we're also going to
have to mount
the efi partition from our usb disk
our usb drive is called the install mac
os big sur
so first i'll select option 2
to mount the efi partition from our
hackintosh
now i'll choose the new option 2 for our
usb drive to install mac os big sur
drive
okay both efi partitions are mounted
so we can close this okay i'll
open up the efi partition that's on the
desktop here
and define the other efi partition
once i when i have the finder selected
i'll go to the go menu at top
and then select computer and you can see
now we can see
both efi partitions not just the one
showing up on the desktop
so i will click the other efi partition
that's been mounted
okay so i have a folder for each efi
partition that are that's mounted one
efi
partition has some folders in it
and the other efi partition is empty
so let me back up a bit and now i'll
drag the efi folder from one partition
to the other partition so now both efi
partitions
have the efi folder in it okay
now i can just restart the computer and
right after the computer turns off
but before it reboots right back up i
need to remove the usb drive
and if i take the usb drive out then the
computer should boot right back up into
mac os
and there you have it the hackintosh is
complete
i had no trouble setting up the
bluetooth or the wi-fi they just worked
and i had no problem connecting the
apple trackpad i've been using this
hackintosh for a few weeks now
and i even used it to edit this video
this very video that you're watching
so far i haven't had any issues and it's
running great so good luck creating your
own hackintosh